[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys
official nations well we've got d-chicks
welcome back hey
it's been a minute huh i haven't seen
you in like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you guys gave me the broke ass chair no
these chairs some of them are booby
trapped yup i was sitting here the other
day i just fell out somehow i don't even
know how that was crazy also did that
answer your question yeah last time i
was here it was so long that this seat
worked oh that's true
we had better chairs a lot of things
worth two years ago
do you want to talk about it no it was
like three years ago give us a crash
course
update on what's been going on so many
things uh i've been at home i've been
eating [ __ ] yeah
sick i feel like people either got way
bigger or way
fitter during the pandemic or way poor
who got fitter just one person no i
gained 30 pounds
that's true he gained it on his ass i
remember i was gonna fight his ass i was
training for the marathon so i was
actually getting leaner right and then
right when the marathon was over in
march is when the pandemic hit and i
just ate and i had all that freezer food
it's also i can't let this go to waste
so i'm eating frozen pizza like once a
week and i gained 30 pounds by uh
i think by december but then i ended up
losing it after oh and now you're just a
god we're talking about the pandemic is
still happening dude well like i guess
it's a two year after the halftime the
second part of the half time whatever it
is you look sexy now so
good job i went into this guy's freezer
he had like eight ice creams dude who
has eight i love ice cream he wants a
variety what's your favorite ice cream
oh it used to be mint chocolate chip but
then i found this ice cream shop next to
my house they do this thing called uh
gram
central
where it's like sounds like weed it's
crushed well graham has a graham cracker
it's crushed graham crackers with
blobs of random chocolate and
marshmallow in this kind of cinnamony
ice cream it's [ __ ] good that's not
ice cream dude you're [ __ ] eating
like a whole different dessert man it's
like a s'more
frozen s'mores
it sounds like cold stuff like there's
hot cheetos yeah what's your favorite
ice cream he's like he's describing his
cold stone order
i hold it down thrifty bro thrifty's the
best ice cream ever
and it's like two bucks still that's
what's your favorite flavor there
chocolate molten crunch is that yeah
oh i never had that these little crunchy
things on the inside oh my god crunchy
dude i'm horny you get the 50s bucket or
do you get them below the column
the cylindrical shape and [ __ ] dude they
got the bird they got the pints at
thrifty now you can get them at not
thrifty too i was at like some some gas
station and they had them there and
nikki's favorite is chocolate multiple
crunch oh they sell the thrift i've
never tried that damn they're branching
out the cookies it's hands down the
[ __ ] best chocolate multiple you know
what they need to do is they need to
sell that damn [ __ ] ice cream
like cylindrical scoop [ __ ] yeah that
you [ __ ] put in and you scoop it out
like a gun and it comes out perfectly
they should sell ice cream scoopers
like that i really think that would be a
good idea but where do you get it i
don't know where you get perfect
cylinder nobody knows dude yeah cause it
comes it's like uh like the size of a uh
like a soup can yeah but you know you
know to tell you the truth i never even
looked that's why i don't know if they
sell it i'm trying to look for
especially thrifty babies i'll buy that
[ __ ] right [ __ ] now dude oh dude it's
not bad they have the legit exact words
they don't got the thrifty one no really
look it says thrifty stainless steel
cylindrical ice cream scoop
24.99 and it's called the cylindrical
ice cream i made that [ __ ] [ __ ] up 25
bucks though just use your hair hell
yeah this was joe's idea this is [ __ ]
up yeah dude they're taking your [ __ ]
been selling it bro they are selling it
off of righted so it does look pretty
like legitimate but right it is thrifty
dude right dude the best is have you
guys been to a rite aid lately yup i got
my pfizer vaccine there so yeah the when
you go to the ice cream part they're
basically like oh for yup
oh yeah why do they get pissed every
time yeah they're like
cause they're well cause they're working
the register too
they're never at the ice cream place you
gotta [ __ ] walk all the way back to
the register
that's why they're constantly checking i
get it like the other registers you're
standing there and there's nobody there
and then they look at you and they're
like oh for [ __ ] yeah i hate the
[ __ ] scooping of ice cream dude they
hate it yeah i'm gonna get that dude 25
bucks is going to be the best that's
going to change your life i've ever
spent that'll be sick what ice cream do
you like do you have a big tub at home
vanilla bro do you use like a little
pint though
i don't even ice cream
that's a dick scooper do tricks know
about the dark knight i don't know but i
want that ice cream scooper
i just love the ice cream i don't want
the scooper almost comes out of it it's
a it's a very uh popular sex toy that
we're all up on oh a different type of
ice cream we're way up on it we bought
it early and we're way up on it yeah
yeah yeah it's going to up now you're
going to crazy we have one we need to
order one one dark knight to split
between the rest
so we came across this a few weeks ago
and it's this theme that has a suction
cup and it does this crazy gyrating
motion and it looks like it'll make you
come in two seconds and it does dude it
does make you come too and it's got a
suction cup handle you tried it dude we
all tried it we all have one that we
wrote around all over i would want to go
how much is it
i'm going first it's 69.99 that's a good
price you buy two you get 20 off if you
buy three you get 25 if you buy four you
get 30 off dude we should have a dark
knight party where we pass it around yes
oh we make eye contact the whole time
yeah yeah we do a little mushroom like
hot potato you turn off the light when
you throw it back on see who has it
yeah and then they win or they lose i
think why can't we just have each of our
own yeah first one to shoot it's like
it's so expensive eye contact what if
it's like human centipede we take the
suction cup we put it on the back side
of everybody and then we stand in a line
and it's a conga line yeah and we do
eye contact guys i should still obsess
with that look back at it look over your
shoulder every now and then like this oh
remember that game you play uh
was it like 30 seconds in heaven or
something you go in the closet so was it
seven minutes i don't know dude joe got
rejected
i never played um it's actually 30
seconds i know it's 30 seconds my
lawyer's here
oh okay that's just in the movies that
doesn't
last 30 seconds that's why
so we're gonna sit we're gonna stick
that in the [ __ ] closet right and you
guys got 30 min 30 seconds to finish and
if you can't the door opens up it's like
a public bathroom dang if you can 30
seconds so your goal is to try and bust
you gotta try to come fast have you ever
actually done that in 30 seconds yeah
that's why guys come quick they're all
trying to break the world record yup
we're very competitive better very
competitive we're champions
my goal is to be a three punk chump that
would be a little bit of a cool like
social weird thing right it's like
that's who can come fast yeah because
obviously it's like yo who can last a
long time but wouldn't be [ __ ] funny
you just live in the world like what's
the fastest you ever came i'm trying to
be first place probably 45 seconds i
went against my brother my brother had a
competition we didn't look at each other
yeah why not did you time it he thought
it was weird i was like what the [ __ ]
you said you went against him it sounds
very interesting yeah who can come who
can come first were you shooting at each
other no no no but i would destroy them
because i got distance bro anybody else
got distance
i do have distance it's like crazy like
distance i'm pretty good distance i have
dribble dude 100 i never tried shooting
it what do you mean i can't help it it
just does it on its own well you just
hand it out slowly no i just i like
green pies dude that's it i like cream
pies mine's like when uh when a guy
slips on a diving board
[Applause]
and then the scoreboard because that was
like zeros yeah exactly is it the short
dive or the high dive either one it's
the same it's the same problem
comes out like a [ __ ]
chinese diver did in the olympics
i have to lock that up so what does that
mean no splash
no splashes
it just disappears it's like
just
you're a distant star too honestly that
thing always shoots at like i can't um
gauge the distance yeah it's hard man
you never know how far it's going to go
i contain it huh ah this is telling me
how you guys like to come explode
joe's excited about this he's a
connoisseur dude you're trying to come
like a [ __ ] circus cannon
like a man in a circus cannon just
[ __ ] explode no that tells me you
like to [ __ ] nut
outside so you pull out you [ __ ] jack
off on the face on the body whatever
that's how you know how much you [ __ ]
shoot a true chromologist yeah
i came on my face before on your own yup
accidentally that's how i found out i
was a like a far shooter yeah i was on
my back and then it went and i thought i
was just like chillin
like three seconds later yeah yeah it
had arch damn dude do you look at
yourself in the mirror like i have a
piece of [ __ ]
after you watch your face laughter
my own property where did it land smile
on my chin but you know the post calm
guilt right then you gotta come all over
your face too
did you go like this did you go
no
no we're laughing
testing the waters just testing it yeah
let's see like quantum control oh no
like this was like him bart and yeah
yeah no that was just like over 10 years
ago but i was i was
trying to pull out so i won't [ __ ]
bust inside
and then i pulled it out and then it did
the toilet though
like a door stopper
and then it went
[ __ ] uppercut me and [ __ ] and i went
back and i walked in your health bar
drained
that's how this pull-out is oh no
you got a cartoon dick bro that's crazy
i can't believe it took us five whole
minutes to not talk about dicks
but like pretty good how are we going
today's video is brought to you by
upstart if looking at your credit card
statements make you want to scream you
are not alone that's why upstart is here
to help you see the light at the end of
the tunnel upstart is the fast and easy
way to pay off your debt all with a
personal loan all online whether you're
paying off credit cards or consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment to find a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans from a thousand to up to
50 000
wow
and receive your funds as soon as the
next business days after you get
accepted so fast find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today by
going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record loan amounts will be
determined by your credit income and
other information that you put on your
loan application that's upstart.com off
the record and don't forget to use the
url so they know that we sent you guys
bye-bye thank you upstart it went from
ice cream to dicks dude the second we
got to cylindrical scoop why did you
pull out the [ __ ] dark knight steve
inspires me it was the scooper now
everyone's been sending me sex toys
right now it was so horrible until you
pulled out the sex toy i have to say we
did bring a lot of visibility to the
dark knight no question yeah do you feel
like we should get like promo code
who first found this who brought this up
no no we were watching porn
and then the dark knight came up as a
pop-up ad it was an episode often times
we randomly uh find some i think the
contest we might have been looking up
somebody's old like celebrity sex tape
or some random [ __ ] right yeah i think
it was a movie that you had mentioned
somebody who yeah
and then there's this [ __ ]
advertisement whereas you know those
advertisers are always they almost look
like gifs they're they're like yeah yeah
480p like [ __ ] fast thumbnail 2x
speed things it works though it sticks a
suction cup on the wall and you see the
dick in and it's just rotating this is
like skinny-ass dude the huge piece like
man
i haven't seen dietrich's in like three
four years and then you had to bring the
[ __ ] into this picture i wouldn't want
it any other way i was i was just trying
to get to know the real him dude oh [ __ ]
yeah hey let's you know let's take the
dicks out of this the dick trick let's
put the dicks into it
what is the d stamp or is it the dick
trix that now did you catch kova in the
last two or three years good question i
think so good transition you never tried
you went from dicks to copenhagen i was
just thinking because he was like let's
get the real story what is the real
story that united he just like
re-scrambled the word dick he's like oh
yeah
yeah i think so you never tested it no
no because it was the year before it
like popped off so no one really knew i
went to my homies indian wedding and
half the party uh had like the worst
fevers of their lives
and i was out for two days and i've
never felt like that oh [ __ ] you're only
out for two days
oh good
no it started probably like two days
before but two days like in bed
uh not knowing that it was two days that
passed what were your symptoms other
than fever i don't i remember i was just
like passed out the whole time the fever
was the worst that's when i went into
the doctor
there's no great ending i'm alive i
guess that's kind of cool yeah that's
really did it [ __ ] with your breathing
no
uh the fatness hat it has though did you
get sleep apnea yeah when i was fat as
[ __ ] i got sleep apnea what's the apnea
mean again well you're like this and
you're sleeping
and it feels like oh you're just
beatboxing no no no no
uh i i think i snore i don't know about
all that that's that was you don't choke
when you're sleeping sometimes you ever
took yourself to wake up actually choke
yourself to wake up while you're
sleeping and he and then you wake up did
you know you were choking well that
that's that's not happening to me what
happens to me though but people that
would sleep after that happens too yeah
you ever drown in your dream and then
you're like can't breathe in real life
i've fallen and i wake up like this
yeah dude that happens to me you've
drowned in a dream before yeah yeah like
my head's on the pillow and like i can't
breathe and then my in my dream i can't
breathe you're suffocating yourself yeah
and then i but then i wake up thankfully
i'm just i am here after all and that
[ __ ] fish comes out wow
wow i don't know i'm just seeing i like
the imagination world zoom between
dimensions and [ __ ] it's probably the
dream in real life in real life i
imagine things that happen in your dream
right you wake up oh it's just a dream
but it's real steve doesn't own fish i
don't have fish dude so how'd that
happen why would you anyway yeah you're
right you're right let's take it back to
somebody listen i'm not i'm not against
you on this i think it's a great
imagination
the artists have to keep it down here
yeah i get it keep that [ __ ] to yourself
i get it but
just make it funny next time yeah you
know i will say on sleep apnea oh i have
this problem where i don't snore like a
like a i don't know a [ __ ] cartoon
snore like me me me me me
who doesn't mean
no i do i do that choking sound
or like
yeah like like you sound like you're
dying yeah yeah you know in the middle
of your sleep you're like
just rossell yeah just like [ __ ]
dying you know and then uh every um
because i used to like travel with dudes
all the time when we were like teaching
stuff and people was like dude are you
okay and they wake me up and i'm like
yeah i'm fine what the [ __ ] you wake me
up like dude
you stopped breathing you sound like
you're dying and i just learned that
that's what i that's a problem
oh the rhythm was probably off it's
weird when skinny dudes got um sleep
apnea because usually like when you gain
weight you have visceral fat and it's
like squeezing up all your [ __ ] lungs
and organs inside that's why it's like
choking you sounds like science yeah
pretty scientificals
[Laughter]
was that a sneeze laugh
no
it's uh apparently it's a not welcome
laugh i'm not walking
yeah you gotta laugh out of here you
can't
[Laughter]
hey did you go out during like
times like when lockdown was going on
like did you go out like illegally doing
[ __ ] no no like not like that but like
like did you socialize and stuff yeah
a lot oh because i didn't even see it on
your instagram
you kept it low-key we had like more
friends like like a lot of parties like
of like friends from like our hometown
that live in l.a cause people got mad at
you for hanging out with other people
during covet yeah if you made it public
yeah people are like why are you
gathering like people will love doing
initially yeah unless you're protesting
that's true we're protesting yeah
obviously a lot of people like you know
kobe
changed a lot of [ __ ] um like what was
probably the biggest life change for you
oh probably 40 pounds other than the
gaining of the weight you look sick is
that the is that the biggest you've ever
been yeah really yeah i think i got to
210 and i'm usually 155.
oh whoa yeah like eight like abc moons
ago it like 155.
yeah well abdc were all malnourished
sure that was not healthy environment in
general
third world country
dancers i mean what about like work and
stuff like that like what have you been
nothing
sick man you made it
[ __ ] major yes
maybe you needed to just chill the [ __ ]
out because of how hard you've been like
hustling for so long i'll say this like
i'm an extrovert usually
uh and so like staying inside all that
time did that [ __ ] you up
yeah cause you know like you talk a lot
but then like when one's around you kind
of still talk just inside yourself it's
equally as loud
uh but nah i i like i kind of liked it
you didn't feel like you missed people
or missed people's energy no because i
think i still had them over
hmm i thought you didn't change so you
didn't really change anything no if
anything i kind of went out more than i
usually do
like kind of during coping because no
one was around so it's kind of still
like uh there was no crowds anywhere
unless you go to like you know
uh like huntington beach or like we're
done like yeah yeah yeah yeah republican
orange county the red hats are a little
bit you know more stern yeah more stern
everybody was out but when you go with
quest crew and we still look like quest
crew
we look like we're not supposed to be
there but
[Laughter]
we're having a blast in orange county
yeah they shame you if you wear a mask
out there
they give
a little bit you gotta get beat up a
little bit i went to i went to a
friend's powerlifting meet in florida
and i'm just used to california rules at
the time yeah and i walked indoors into
the gym and i had a mask on and everyone
looked at me weird i was sure did they
spit on you no but it was like oh this
is this fool was like the stranger in
the saloon when he opened up the double
doors and everyone looked over there
they were like you better be a [ __ ]
kenja or a half jabberwocky or go the
[ __ ] home but it was also freeing
because it almost just felt like
let's get back to normal
it was it's actually kind of nice yeah
yeah i like it i'm a fan of not working
and i was in a room with i don't know
[ __ ] like 300 people i didn't catch
covet did i catch it already i don't
should have made out with more people
you got to start feeding people more
steak and [ __ ] you know i passed that
over you didn't catch it because you're
the one giving it
oh i learned a lot about family
and like uh because that's like it's big
on belief right so inside the family
there's different beliefs this topic was
like a weird one of hearing like
everybody's belief so it was really cool
what's your favorite take on it yeah the
people that are super split on it like
yeah yes i believe in this i think it
just comes down to at least for me it
was just more i let it be for other
people because with or without the match
for me like i'm pretty this like the
same what about the 5g theories do you
have anybody in your family people say
5g made people get coveted so people
were like burning down 5g towers and
[ __ ] like that yeah dude
all right that's one yeah
so what is six g gonna do then probably
get more coverage
reporting according to them yeah
according to i don't know i it might is
kind of [ __ ] up but i feel like it's
worth it for the i like the new iphone
what they're saying dude 5g is pretty
good i don't want to try to make this
[ __ ] fast
faster bro i don't give a [ __ ] if you
could download it into my [ __ ] brain
i would i would have a chip in my head i
can't wait to get chips elon's narrowly
you guys have the new iphone the iphone
13 with the new cinematic mode or
whatever i'm gonna get it though i don't
know i got it ordered my girlfriend got
it for me for my birthday which uh just
passed and uh thank you for the birthday
shout out but the rest of you guys [ __ ]
off
sorry happy birthday happy birthday dude
when was it uh the 15th it was oh that's
type oh you're sagittarius uh i'm
dietrix
[ __ ] oh sorry i thought you i saw
somebody else uh libra libra libra i
don't really know what that means i
don't know anything i think that means
you don't know anything like tigers i'm
not mad at them
were you born with the gap between your
tooth uh no
but i had a a lot of gum that's a libra
thing it was like a gap between libra
because that's what jill keeps telling
me she's like what libra's got getting
she was born with the gap and then she
was something that's part of a libra
thing i'm a libra but so far it's wrong
she's gonna lie to you about a lot of
things i'm definitely not a true libra
then what about if you have an underbite
that's me i'm a libra and i gotta you're
a libra
when's your birthday there's a gap
somewhere 24th or september everybody's
giving it to people that's like dig
better what about overbite because
that's mine i got the freddie mercury
thing oh yeah you got the chompers going
on so i'm a libra tube what does this
mean i'm not good at giving head well
let's find out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you